the united nations say the pacific
island nation of tonga suffered
significant damage in saturday's
volcanic eruption the first images are
starting to emerge after new zealand and
australia sent surveillance planes to
the area communication has been limited
after the country's only internet cable
was cut new zealand is also sending
ships carrying water and other supplies
but planes can't land because of a
blanket of ash covering the main
airport's runway
a prelude to a violent eruption
on friday the hungar tonga hunga hapai
volcano sent plumes of smoke and ash
shooting into the sky
activity that soon decreased
it would prove to be a brief respite
the next day
the volcano rumbled to life again
in an explosion so powerful it sent
shock waves around the world
before and after satellite images
show how the volcano sea level crater
had disappeared following the blast
with regular communication lines to
tonga cut off the world's been relying
on satellite phones and images to get a
sense of the disaster
we are still waiting to receive
uh information from tonga of what is
much needed but we know for sure that
there will be a
need for clean water because of the air
eruptions and
which really
imagine causing lots of
troubles to the water supplies in china
as most of the people collect water
through rain and this is something very
dangerous for them to consume
australia and new zealand have sent
surveillance flights to help assess the
scale of the damage especially on
tonga's outer islands where there are
fears the devastation could be immense
joining us now is shane cronin a
volcanologist from the university of
auckland uh shane do we know more now
about the situation in tonga after the
surveillance flights by new zealand and
australian planes
yeah good morning we do we do know a lot
more and also uh some of the satellite
imagery that's been uh collected through
the un uh program and so we've seen
extensive damage due to the tsunami and
also
ash hall across most of the islands
thankfully the asheville is not too
thick so mainly around two centimetres
thick on the main island of tonkitapu
and some of the other
islands to the north have looked like
they have a little thicker ash
and
and then the tsunami damage is
mainly confined to two or three very
low-lying islands where there's major
damage most of the others have
relatively um
well
major damage but not let's say it's not
affecting a lot of where the housing is
so we spoke 24 hours ago and then you
were somewhat optimistic that damage in
tonga itself from the eruption was not
that bad are you still optimistic about
that
uh and well i i think that the tsunami
damage is is slightly more than what i
was expecting and the but the ash ball
damage um is about what we were
expecting so the two centimeters of ash
is not enough to to damage structures
but obviously uh it needs to be cleaned
from the from the airstrip
and also
it
it needs to be
the water supplies need to be secured
and as your previous correspondent
mentioned
around 80 percent of tongans
in use rainwater
supplies particularly
outside the main and the main uh
settlement of nuka lofa
is there any danger of more eruptions
you think
yes there is and so we're working on uh
very simple scenarios um
uh the the largest of these scenarios
would be uh the concern that the upper
part of the volcano is now very unstable
so after that initial eruption the top
part of the volcano
now is going to be fractured it's
changed its shape a lot and the concern
is if new magma rises into that upper
volcano system it could it could cause
more instability and therefore more
explosive events so those are that's the
uh worst case scenario we're planning uh
for the other scenarios would be um that
the gas rich magma has now
being erupted from the system and so
that the next lot of magma may have uh
an easier path to the surface and the
eruptions may be slightly smaller so
those are the two scenarios we're
looking at um and because there's no
monitoring
possible on the volcano at the moment
we really are relying on
having frequent visual observations via
satellite imagery to see what is
happening at the v site
shane cronin then a volcanologist from
the university of auckland thank you
shane
thanks for the interest again
you